بالكهرباء ازدحام الأشعة السينية
لا يوجد حد لعبقرية
تقدم أي كائن علمي محسوب
تزن أعتقد أن الحياة واحدة
المعادلة لحلها
رباح نويل سافاري أثينا مبنى في
مجتمع كالينجين في جميلة هو
ليس سيئا لذلك
نهائي كما في ليبيا أو بوردو
لذا احرص على أن تقاوم تانا و
لافال
على الأرض
كل
نفكر في بؤس اليورو للجميع
آلة المحرك الحلويات في الصين
لأن هناك وظيفة هذا الصباح 26 في هايتي
من 10 كم إلى آخر nathanaël gimone
كانت سامية هناك لحظة وصول الشرطة 10 صباحا
شارب وياهو فعلت
سحب ابنته ماري تيبرت من 10 إلى 12
الأسرة التي نسيها في تيميشوارا
رئيس مع 15 والش و aux واقعية
نحن في فيلم المتمردين
أخيل المعاقين فعلنا هذا
هل سيجعل تلفزيون الويب ماري هيلين
يهودا لنا هل فضل
نظام غذائي مماثل كصديق جانبي
قانون 10 عمر الثلاثينات يخرج كل شيء
إن اللمفاوي ifa لن يريده
لا شيء لتلك المناجم بالمئات
كل جزيرة فيها مع sifel Farida
المآذن
واشنطن تصنع ولكن كم طن
من الصلب الياقوت سيعرف من أعاد بناء الكيلومتر
أتنزا إلى ophélie gropes وسيكون الأمر كذلك
مناجم أبييم في كريتيل ب ماسينرو كابول
حيث تجلس في مانيسا حيث فعل
ليس التنفس المعتاد ولكن الإضاءة
المئات والعلا أتالاي في ناربون
استيقظ سنقوم بتحسينه بالفعل في كندا
مليار من مناجم الأفوكادو العضوية
سوناتيل انتهى في صابرينا الفرح الذي
بن بن ماك كين أراك قريبًا جدًا من الخير
إخراج شهر العطاره
مثل kolo أعمى حديقتي
أعشاب عين الفاشر مشهد فيلو لحسن
غرفة كمال الخطيب في ألبون الحفلة
لمست كل الموتى و
المباني adoli أفضل تسليح من
القوات هناك أسست الفاصوليا توريل هانسن لديه
قال لتوبا عشرة ملاعب يسيل لعابها
بالتأكيد ماتيلا فيات يحتجز الأبيض
قال لي أيضا آه إذا كان هناك مور
Who is a hit theolia nasa diane no
تدليك تساعد بالفعل على الكرات
واليا لماذا المقصورة لي
من شأنه أن يطلق سيريل ثم على مؤسسة أودي
مريض ولكن غير قابل للتخزين syfy wyeth
الجنة حيث سيكون هذا الشراء في النهاية لـ
كيلومتر جعلتها المايا ابنة
مملكة
معاناتي وأشعل النار في سخط
رئيس فيشر هو وقت طويل في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
في mclaren mois الممرات المائية الداخلية
هل يوجد منجم تزلج؟
انتظر هناك ني نيوزيلندا
فريق aaa talio الحب للقائد
اذهب يا مانهارت إلى wamme akassato
أصيلة طوني لامب فقط فعلت إيطاليا
للقيام الثقيلة ويحيى الامانة ديس
حدود ukba izmir حيث يظهر نيكولاس
واوا بوختال وطالبان ولكن هناك
samaras في بردا صنعاء الاسمية ت
المعطي عبر صديق والأفلام بسهولة
لقد أسس أسلحة بيضاء يلعبونها كما يخبرنا
آلان شباط في العمل ولف الصور
ذريعة كاذبة لكل متعاون
سنا الله هذا هو المكان الذي سيأخذ فيه wakan
بريان فاريل cia يدين بعقب
حاول أن يرمق إلى أي مدى هو
نحن في حوليات أشهر الوحش الذي كان يحلم به
براديرا أمس بسرعة عالية آرتي
سيتشين الماهر ولكن أمين آل الوزن
سيئة للغاية أسفل الألغام الثلاثاء الأمل التمهيد
قلت إن جواً للسعوديين
العدو الحميم في أفلام روما
المسلسلات اليوم
يأمل لي كونو فيرينزي جنسن
رهامسين هاواي المكتسبة أثناء الورم الخبيث
هي أخلاق الوحش الذي يستيقظ عند الملك
المغناطيس مع ما عيب هناك نيكولاس
حساسة حيدري أعطيه السيد نهلة
أنت كروما تفاري إيان موريسون و
فقط الدنماركية مشاهدة الطحينة في مانيلا au
إعادة التعديل سيعززنا timakova و
لعبة ماريا تيني ليس غدا على هذا الرقم في
في camac سنوات لتشغيل و mathilde
شاديان نيكولا اتصل إذا اعترف
يجب أن يكون الملك آرا ماليكيان بلربيا له
تفاصيل تمرير تعطي والله
rqra ونرى المزيد من التبغ
التصوير الشعاعي للثدي يمنى باستون ليفد ليه
البريد الحمم macana لفتاة oicha
ممر
و
دفن الروح للمهرب الذي تحمله
في مستقبل النادي
سيرينا ميشول بشاري عبدان بطة
كزافييه ميمون ناسيل لويزيانا سيتولى الأمر
أصيلة رطل يستحق قال إيان مارتن في
عنابة قساوسة مارانا ليو بايدا
murielle hilaire الروح aminatou
ساموثريس سيدتي مرحبا وشكرا على ذلك
يستلم
مرحبا سيدتي الخوري اهلا وسهلا بك
متحف القس شكرا لك كوديعة أو
في خلنا حياة العروش عنده
نجا منه البحث القس و
الكابينة التي ستحتفل بالشمس أو
nerthe to balard over bidaya ثم نحن
بجوار هذه الصورة الشهيرة لـ
لويس باستور رسمها إديل فيت لويس
انتصر القس على الغضب منذ ذلك الحين
في الواقع كان ذلك في يوليو 1885
لديك ولد صغير اسمه
جوزيف ميستر الذي كان شريرا
عض من قبل كلب مسعور وبالتالي مع
والدته وصاحبة الكلب
غاضب
سوف يذهبون إلى باريس للقاء
السيد لويس باستير لأننا نعلم
أن لويس باستور يعمل وقد تطور
ليس لقاحًا يعمل جيدًا
على الحيوانات حتى الصغيرة في الواقع
سيد سيكون أول ولد
تلقي هذا اللقاح ضد
الغضب والجميع يعرف القصة
يخلص الطفل بعد ذلك بما فيه الكفاية
بعد فترة وجيزة هناك شاب ثان
الرجل الذي يوشك أن يصل الراعي مبتهج
الذي عضه كلب أيضًا
غاضب ومن سيفعل أيضًا
السفر لتلقي هذا اللقاح
هنا مرة أخرى لقاح ناجح و
لذلك من هناك سيكون لديك
عض كما كان يطلق عليهم في ذلك الوقت
من سيبدأ في التدفق من كل مكان و
حتى من بعيد جدًا منذ ذلك الحين على سبيل المثال
هناك تسعة عشر روسيًا تعرضوا للعض
في بداية عام 1886 بواسطة ذئب
غاضبون في قريتهم والذين يذهبون
اذهب أيضا إلى باريس لتلقي
ولذلك فإن اللقاح الذي طوره
القس وعلى روسه التسعة عشر الطيبين
حسنًا ، سيتم إنقاذ ستة عشر ثلاثة
لا يزال يتطور المرض
تزول وهي في الواقع في هذا
السياق هناك أن اشتراك كبير
وطنية وحتى دولية
سيتم إطلاقها لإنشاء معهد
الذي سيأخذ اسم القس
معهد الباستور أن الجميع
يعرف اليوم
على هذا الحائط باستيل من صنع لويس
قس يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا وهو علاوة على ذلك
صورة لأمه نعم التأخير
لويس القس للسيدات الحجر الصحي
عندما إخواننا هكذا نعم القس أ
تطوير لقاحات أخرى ولكن
بشأن أمراض الحيوان
التطعيم الأول الذي أتى به
النقطة هي التي تهم أ
المرض الذي تم استدعاؤه قبل
كوليرا الطيور التي عمل عليها
أمراض الحيوانات الأخرى وعلى وجه الخصوص
أيضا على سبيل المثال على مرض
الفحم الذي لمس الأزرار
قبل أن يتحول إلى داء الكلب الذي
كان مرضًا بقدر ما كان حيوانًا
من الإنسان
ثم بعد ذلك في استمرارية
هذه التطعيمات ، على وجه الخصوص ،
إنشاء معهد باستور
سوف يستمر باستوريان بالطبع
القيام ببعض البحوث
لتطوير لقاحات أخرى
على سبيل المثال ، تحديد
لا يزال فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية أيضا في عام 1983 بنسبة اثنين
البستوري الذي كان لديه علاوة على ذلك
ثم حصل على جائزة نوبل لهذا الاكتشاف
معهد الباستور اليوم أ
خصوصية لا يزال لديك 32
معاهد في جميع القارات وهي
على وجه الخصوص ، هناك ثلاثة معاهد باستور في
المغرب العربي
أوه
هنا أدعوك لاكتشاف
هذا القبو الذي دفن فيه
لويس باستور مدهش للغاية
لذلك في الواقع كنا نتخيل ذلك
القس في البانثيون الجيد ولكن فيه
الحقيقة أنه اختيار الأسرة
سيدتي القس وأطفالها الذين يذهبون
اطلب من لويس باستور ذلك
البقاء بشكل استثنائي في
المعهد الذي ساعد في إنشائه و
في الواقع ، معهد الباستور ذاهب إلى
تخطيط الأسرة هذا المكان
الذي كان قبو فيه واحد
لقاحات داء الكلب المخزنة
وكانت العائلة هي التي قامت بتجهيزه
هذا المكان حتى القس هنا
سيدتي موريل هيلير تحت
شوكولاتة الجزيرة لخواد وماريو مات
شكرا وداعا شكرا لك انها أ
يسعدني أن أرحب بكم في متحف الباستر
شكرا جزيلا
هدم
أوه